sgs und herzlich willkommen zur neuen
video und hoffentlich zu dem letzten
video zu dem ganzen goldesel bfs hat
sich wieder einiges ergeben in letzter
zeit für die nicht wissen warum geht es
gehe darum dass ich mich über eine
werbung lustig gemacht habe und dann der
youtuber der die ansage aus dem kanal
gebracht hat eine ansage gegen mich
gemacht hat weil er gedacht hatte ich
will ihn beleidigen und er an dieser
anlage gegen mich nicht noch mal richtig
beleidigt und in wir gescheitert von fg
was ich und seine zuschauer auf meinen
kanal geld da und dann etwas krasseste
postiert okay leute und das ist der
entscheidende touristen die der ganzen
sache das unternehmen hat dann die
ansage von diesen youtuber genommen die
andere gehen der mich beleidigt und in
der er sich schon ein bisschen schulen
verbessert und das unternehmen nimmt
diese ansage eine ansage dass eine
beleidigung und schalten die als werbung
wie dumm kann man eigentlich sein was
das doch mal ein video mit uns zusammen
gemacht
ok ok 890 gemacht wurde und andere
youtuber beleidigt ja ich glaube das
passt perfekt in unser
unternehmensprofil gewollten sowieso als
unternehmen darstellen was beleidigung
unterstützt und schwulenfeindliche
aussagen unterstützt also schon mal
richtig richtig richtig dumm da ging
relativ grunddaten news darüber
berichtet max ob sich darüber aufgeregt
dürften everybody austria für merkwürdig
vorkommt das war der absolute gipfel
dieser ganzen sache wenn die der
youtuber der sich ganz geschafft hat
mich dann beleidigt und so alles klar
soll das machen aber ein unternehmen
leute da muss doch jemand dahinter
stecken der halbjahre vom leben hat dass
die eine ansage nehmen und die als
werbung schalten
achtung nicht akkurat sport auf youtube
leute denen er steht in der cola vor der
kamera und schreib einfach ihr
[ __ ] die kamera und das wird
eingeschaltet weil werbung im jahr 2017
scheinbar aus beleidigung bestehen muss
das wollte ich noch erzählen was ich da
noch was ganz neues ergeben hat und es
ist darum hatten von youtube auf richtig
hoch geschwappt ist dieser youtuber der
die anlage nicht gemacht hat dann die
der ansage wie vor als werbung
geschaltet wurde gelöscht
die gibt es nicht mehr ich habe es
natürlich noch am alten video the water
statement video vom sk lenk ist das
köpfchen ja hier sind gehört die
beleidigende werbung immer wieder weg es
gibt eine neue ansage obwohl er nicht
mehr beleidigt und sich für die
beleidigung in der beleidigenden werbung
entschuldigt das wollte ich noch
erzählen weil es
dass irgendein unternehmen auch richter
einmischte beleidigen inhalte was ich
alles das ist einfach mitlaufen aber
selbstverständlich dass der kurs myvideo
zu viele leute deswegen machen wir heute
auch noch eine fragerunde einsätze juni
in der ihm ihr eure fragen zu dieser
ganzen geschichte stellen könnt viele
von euch haben sich auch sorgen gemacht
sie beleidigt wieder unter druck gerate
und einfach das alles mal klarzustellen
zu beantworten gute frage bist du jetzt
darüber gedacht ich dachte mir lustig
als für eigentlich habe ich mich fast
ein bisschen darüber gefreut leute weil
es einfach so auf wie wichtig war dass
ich diesen bieten so nennen möchte
gewinnen würde weil die gegenseite sich
einfach ziemlich dumm angestellt hat
geklappt es ist quasi gleich gefundenes
fressen
ich finde das ist eigentlich das erste
mal dass du ihn zu einem tief kommst du
da war das schon mal zu gast das erste
mal leute und deswegen mache ich dazu
wird auch ein paar videos einfach weil
das was besonderes für mich ist weil ich
denke wenn sie mich besonders für euch
recht auf besonders weil nämlich schon
etliche dinge zusammen erleben
im nachhinein das ist dass dieses video
gegen goalie viel gemacht hast oder da
stehst du immer noch zum video geiler
hintergrund
ich denke für demnach hinrichtungen so
langsam denke ich mir dass ich
vielleicht mit absicht gemacht haben
dass die mit absicht zu provozieren
wollen was irgendwie eine art von
publicity zu bekommen sagt immer jede
aufmerksamkeit ist gute aufmerksamkeit
aber mit jupp ehrlich gesagt nicht so
viele leute haben ja auch schon gemein
die kritische aufmerksamkeit das stört
mich persönlich nicht für die zehn
klicks mehr auf ihre videos bekommen
solange ich dabei video ideen habe die
ich selbst lustig interessant findet ist
alles cool
die geschichte kam halt mal die
geschichte kann ganz fertig zu stellen
die geschichte kam dadurch zustande dass
ich nicht über die bewerbung von denen
nutzt gemacht dabei mega viele leute mit
ja auch damals schon geschickt haben und
max meine du musst über die werbung
lustig machen da habe ich mich über die
werbung wird es gemacht
[Musik]
es war wirklich aber jetzt sage okay ich
habe keine ahnung ich habe mir diese
herunter geladen ich werde mich auch
nicht runterladen und ich hoffe ihr
ladet ihr euch auch nicht runter nur
wegen des todes nach wie vor steht meine
aussage dass es keinen sinn macht dass
dieses team würde ich für 800 millionen
euro euch alle anlügen und sagen wir die
schuld bin dann 400 millionen für die
fördervereinigung von an gelungen es
kathrin spenden wird ja alle keine
ahnung warum macht er das nicht
persönlich aus dem gleichen grund wieso
ich ein video zu diesem unnötig liegen
da gemacht hat irgend größere youtuber
macht irgendwas versöhnlich ein bisschen
streitpotenzial hat dann geht man
natürlich darauf ein weil das bringt
klickt sonst reichweite und für alle
wohl klicks um reichweite machen sticks
vor auf meiner seite kommen das habe ich
verstanden
gibt es eigentlich bis doch seine band
boney beide trainieren ist toll dass
hunderte alles klar perfekte frage zum
abschluss dieses video zum thema wein
ich kenne meine beine leuten danke fürs
zuschauen last zwei leichter und
selbstverständlich auch einen zeit zu
zeit ist zunächst mal tschüss